is it a bird is it a plane no
it's the top five moves of the strongest
ever computer program
of all time alpha zero
alpha zero was an incredibly strong
invention of demis hazabis and his team
at deepmind
i got these moves with help from very
strong international player matthew
sadler go and check out his youtube
channel
game changer we're gonna now be looking
at those five moves remember to
like and subscribe to this channel over
to example number one in the first
example
we see an amazing move it's white to
play
here can you spot alpha zero's move
this actually has been seen in other
examples
most recently nepo used it in one of his
games to give you a big
clue now what is the move the move
that white played was the simply
astonishing
bishop to b8
take summer at stockfish eight
and this move is amazing because you put
the bishop on a seemingly ridiculous
square
but you're opening up the rook so it can
dive into the action on
g5 the main line goes with black taking
on b8 which
stockfish did not play and now rook
takes g5
this bishop's sacrifice has pulled away
the rook from its defense of the king's
side and black can no longer play a move
such as rook to f6 in this position and
here black could be completely helpless
the winning number when attacking is
generally
three pieces and white has four pieces
here for example
let's say black tries to bring a piece
back to defend
white would now play rook takes h5 check
and here bring in the knight the big
fret here
is bishop to e6 check making way for the
queen
to dive in for example something let's
say like bishop to
c6 we go check and now queen to g6
cutting that king in half and the fret
is knight to h7 with check mate
another very nice threat here is rook to
h8 and if bishop takes
queen to g8 checkmate very nice stuff
so this would have led to an awesome
attack for white the game
actually continued after bishop to b8
with the move queen to e8
and queen to e8 keeps the rook as a
defensive piece
white now played rook takes g5
and after queen to b8 check white now
moved his king
and in this position white has a very
strong attack
black was able to play some very good
defensive moves this was a key idea
white now brought his knight in and the
bishop came into g6
with rook takes h5 to continue the game
continued for a number of moves and it
actually ended with stockfish hanging on
for a draw
but this bishop to b8 move well
what a move to play a seemingly
impossible move
trying to divert your opponent's piece
away to land a vicious blow
on g5 beautiful stuff there from the
incredibly strong computer program alpha
zero
example number two puts us on the black
side of the game
we're playing alpha zero in this
position here
and this is a potential variation in the
game white actually played queen d1
black went on to win but the key move
was what happens if white tries to hold
on to his knight with knight to b5 and
of course alpha zero had seen a
brilliant
possibility here wasn't actually played
in the game but
it was in his calculations can you see
the move
i like this one because it's very
human-like in some way meaning
that we have three pieces attacking
or pointing towards white's king but we
want to try and bring in
more pieces and open up that king and
the move to play have you got it
is bishop 2f3
and the idea of this is to tear open the
white king but also to allow this
rook entrance into a square such as
g6 i think a beautiful move here for
example now if white
captures on f3 we continue with rook a6
and three pieces the magic number is
is too much for white to handle let's
say white tries
king to h1 the rook comes over
and there's too many frets to these
pawns white is completely lost
another very nice line with bishop to f3
is something along the lines of g3
and here black continues by bringing in
the reinforcements again this bishop
cannot be captured because it opens up
the file towards the king
and after king h2 queen to h4
and this is a stunning idea that alpha
zero had
you can't take the queen because it's
pinned and if white tries to
defend a little bit more here then the
rook comes over to g6
and after one more move let's say a4
the rook now sneaks up to g5 can you see
black's idea yet
well let's say a5 i will actually leave
it for you to
find the very nice checkmate that alpha
zero had in mind
so this was the second idea bishop f3
how do you like that
sound onto idea number three now in this
third example we see
alpha zero attacking with real
real strength he sacrificed a piece to
pull out the black king but white is a
piece down
the queen is also attacked so what on
earth does white
do to keep the initiative and it's a
real piece of
geometric beauty this next movement
in the olden days you would afford
computers not possible as such
concepts but clearly they're possible of
things of beauty
in this modern era and what
should the move be well the move can you
see it here
is queen to h1 now this might
not look like a a great move putting the
queen in the corner of the board like
that
but it's astonishing and one of the most
amazing moves i've ever seen
the point is we're going to try to get
rid of a key defender
of the black king the bishop on f5 by
moving our
bishop into e4 and our attack
rages on for example stopfish tried to
defend
now with king to g7
and now the bishop slid into the
position on e4
and after bishop g6 white removes that
defender
and now the queen creeps back out
because it's done its job on that square
it all has
always had chances to come into e4
combined with the two rooks on the open
files and black's bad development and
slightly exposed king
there's nothing that stopfish can do to
save this position
for example bishop to f6 and why else
did the queen move here
because of king g2 beautiful stuff
using the h1 square again but this time
for the rook
and after the rook gets to h1 well
white has a deadly attack which he went
on to convert
in very beautiful style we don't have
enough room to
keep it in this video but go and check
out matthew sadler and natasha reagan's
book
game changer if you want more details on
to example number four
and i've actually seen this plan in
action
in the last game it was kind of used
what is white's idea here's maybe not
one move this but a combination of the
mini plan two moves here to
get another white piece into the attack
but when i say i've seen this plan being
used only
in a very silly sense in a rather
humorous way which is never good for the
side doing it but
now alpha zero plays the astonishing
king 2h2 now again you might be thinking
come on simon what's astonishing about
moving your king
to h2 well if we think about this in
human terms
the black king is quite weak because the
h pawn has been
dragged over here for some unknown
reason
but none of the pieces that white has at
the moment can cause that much damage to
the black king
when you can't cause much damage with
your pieces that out you need to bring
in
the reinforcements come on boys
so what are the reinforcements here well
the rook
on f1 and after black plays
bishop to f8 white now plays rook to h1
and this plan
of king h2 and rook h1 and on the next
move
king g1 is astonishing
the rook has basically jumped over the
king de-castled itself
to now get on to the open h file and to
pressurize
the black king which leads to a winning
attack
a lovely maneuver there and again this
alpha zero program
finding beauty and can computers think
in an artistic sense well
yes they can and one of the
really interesting things of alpha zero
and if you watch the documentary on go
alpha go you'll see the top go player in
the world
also found moves from alpha zero that it
couldn't explain it opened up
new doors of perception and
this is something it's a joy to behold
and that was
one stunning maneuver now the final
example we see
alpha zero in a position with the black
pieces
some messy attacking position i could
even see the likes of kasparov
being black in this in this situation it
looks like
black's attack has dissipated there's
nothing here
white is material up and if black
doesn't find a good continuation black
will just be lost but there is
a move to keep that party going so what
is the move
it is knight to d5
an astonishing way to try and bring the
knight nearer to the white king but
mainly vacating the f6 square for
black's bishop
and if that bishop can get on this open
diagonal the white king will be exposed
the main
line of attack goes pawn takes knight
queen c2 check and after king a1
now e4 the bishop coming to f6
with deadly effects there you can see
this line
is going to be checkmate very soon so
simply
beautiful move this knight d5 the game
continued rook takes d5 bishop takes d5
but after king b1 bishop b7 the game
is now pretty much equal both sides have
weaknesses
white has a poor majority ended in a
draw because both kings are weak
without this astonishing shot knight d5
well
black is just lost sometimes you have to
find
amazing moves in desperate situations
maybe again
a little bit like life we've got to find
and we've got to dig
deep at difficult and in difficult times
five stunning examples there remember to
like
this video please do please do i'm not
gonna beg not much
and subscribe to the chess.com channel
quite possibly
the best chess channel in the universe
this
is really a turning point some would say
in the development
of a i computers being able to think for
themselves that's how alpha zero
was programmed in a very different way
to previous
engines learning from its own mistakes
like a human
would very amazing developments and
could be a big step in our evolution
i hope you enjoyed this video and i'll
be back again with more
soon